ladies and gentlemen
ladies and gentlemen it is here it is
her son manometrism deceased is
back and sansan son tom taylor starts us
off with a bang okay here's the thing
here's the thing right deceased is
finally back superman returns in this
story thank god right so we get to see
whatever came of like zombie superman
was gonna be awesome not a spoiler
because a ton of other stuff happens
here but here's the kicker
as you guys know deceased is a monthly
release which means we cover this one
today we don't cover the next one until
like september like late september
september 20th and then we gotta wait to
the end of october and so on and so
forth right it comes out once a month i
still say they should have released
these as an original graphic novel
having said that this story is amazing
right so what this does and it's
actually one of the coolest things what
this does is it opens up on krypton with
the city of kandor and the origin of
supergirl remember supergirl is a
character that we haven't seen yet in
deceased like we have not seen her yet
and it's one of the cool things because
the more i read dc's the more i think it
kind of feels like injustice in terms of
all of tom taylor's world building and
so what we end up getting here is
supergirl basically being sent away from
krypton by her family and instead of
arriving on earth she travels somewhere
else now all of this is really being
given to us by way of like literally
brainiac showing up here krypton's
imminent end it's destruction all that
kind of stuff what you normally expect
from the origin of supergirl but here's
the cool thing right here's the funny
thing that happens so the statement
that's made by her by her family by her
parents is this it will take many years
for you to reach your new home daughter
though krypton will be long gone to you
it will seem like no time has passed we
have searched throughout the universe
and we have found a planet when you
reach this world you will have
incredible abilities but you will not be
alone in this there will be others on
this world with fantastic powers you
will be special but not apart and when
she arrives here this statement her
parents make is we are sending you to
new genesis jorel would send his son to
live with primitives we are sending you
to live with gods the crazy thing about
this is when she arrives on new genesis
everybody's infected with the anti-life
virus remember like literally dark side
went nuts he was the first to truly be
infected outside of like cyborg but he
was the first the first being to truly
be infected and then seemingly went on a
war path new genesis was hit by that
which means high father and all these
new gods that exist out there in dc
comics they're all zombified if we want
to use that phrase right but they're all
basically they're infected with the
anti-life virus now for those of you
guys coming from marvel comics and
you're not necessarily sure what all
this means imagine that like a being
like galactus was infected with the
anti-life virus and it was like a planet
of galactus's and that's what you're
looking at right that's the kind of
thing you're looking at like the kind of
mid-level cosmic entities so let's say
somebody like mephisto and thanos and
galactus and these guys that's the level
of power that we're talking about here
it's pretty intense now i use those
comparisons as more of like a contextual
thing so before some of you guys get in
the comments and you're like nerfed derp
derp actually thanos is not as powerful
as high father derp de derp i'm not
making a power comparison i'm simply
just saying that like these guys are at
least in terms of the role they play
they're comparable but the thing about
this is where supergirl initially flees
for her life one thing to remember is
that the new gods are in a lot of ways
on her same level of power and so she is
seemingly immediately overtaken by these
guys and then infected by the virus so
quite literally she arrives on this
world and then basically dies and so
following that what you end up doing is
of course you kind of get a little bit
of an explanation from tom taylor in so
far is where things stand which is to
say that yes there was the anti-life
virus that broke out on earth but they
ultimately discovered a cure so while
not every single person across the world
is cured most are and they're still
curing a ton every day but lest we
forget there is basically the
superheroes who exist here on earth but
one of the things you remember is at the
end of the first dc's comic a bunch of
the heroes escaped earth they took off
right they literally got in spaceships
and left they're gone so there are some
superheroes who are still here but a lot
of the ones that we know have basically
taken off and so what we end up doing
here is of course switching over to the
ones who are here right so you have
damien wayne who's the new batman you
have jonathan kent who's the new
superman so on and so forth and what
they're trying to figure out is what
they're going to do initially jonathan's
like now that we have a cure it's time
to go find my dad it's time to go find
superman and to basically save him you
know the other part of this is damian
just being like i can come with you
right like i could i could join you on
this and it's kind of a funny banter
back and forth because jonathan's whole
thing is like i mean it's the center of
the sun damien i doubt batman has the
the ability or any technology i doubt
that bruce had any anything that would
allow him to enter the center of the sun
now as we know from batman comics the
fact that batman is literally this guy
can just reach into his pocket and have
whatever he needs at any point in time
in order to feed somebody because prep
time or something like that he probably
did but it's still a funny thing what's
really cool about this though this is
one of the things that i love about tom
taylor tom taylor's great when it comes
to developing interpersonal
relationships and what is in effect a
post-apocalyptic story right like
injustice kind of felt post-apocalyptic
to a degree in so far as those heroes as
we knew them versus the heroes as they
exist now and then of course like
deceased is absolutely a
post-apocalyptic story where society's
kind of rebuilding itself but the
relationship between jonathan and damian
has largely been maintained these guys
know each other just as well as they
ever did and they've become some of the
best of friends that you could possibly
imagine so it's no wonder why it is that
jonathan is not in any rush to let
damien join him in the center of the sun
not necessarily even knowing if damien
can survive but at the end of the day
the decision is made right because of
the fact that this is essentially
superman and because this is superman
who spent the last five years at the
center of the sun remember when the
whole dc's thing first ended up
happening when it first popped off
towards the end of the story superman
was infected he ended up being infected
by the anti-life virus and when the
heroes were trying to escape those who
managed to get away from earth when they
were trying to take off they were
initially being attacked ultimately
superman was momentarily held off and
then ended up basically walking away
right ended up flying into the sun to
basically charge himself with solar
energy and has been doing so for the
last five years and that's what's kind
of crazy is because when the heaviest
hitters who were here on earth get to
the sun and they get to where superman
is one of course they have the cure but
two they didn't realize how radically
things had changed that when jonathan is
told by green canary right when
basically dinah died a lance black
canary following the death of uh of hal
jordan she basically ended up becoming
the new green lantern that when this
happened that she tells him that's not
your father in there jonathan that's
something that you have to keep in mind
that's not your dad that is an infected
guy so while the goal is to cure him if
it comes down to the fact that we can't
we may have to kill him and that has to
be something that you can be okay with
and while jonathan doesn't necessarily
say that he is at the end of the day he
has to be there's no alternative here
either superman gets cured or superman
has to die and so entering into the sun
what jonathan and really the others
failed to take into account or maybe
just hadn't really been able to
understand the full gravity of is how
powerful superman would become sitting
in the core of the sun for five straight
years absorbing all of its solar energy
like just standing there absorbing solar
energy right i mean superman is powered
by solar energy so he's faster and
stronger than anybody could have ever
imagined and faster and stronger than
he's ever been in his existence a
perfect example of this is that green
canary literally creates a hard light
construct to encase superman and tom
taylor kind of plays with this idea and
saying that under any normal
circumstance this would have held him
under any normal circumstance superman
would have been encased and he would
have been able to get away he would he
shattered it in an instant right just
like literally just broke it like glass
now with enough time normal superman
probably would have been able to escape
but that's one of the things to know
about tom taylor's writing his depiction
of characters from one story to the next
outside of dc's continuity really
changes so superman during injustice for
example was stupidly overpowered i mean
it was nuts how powerful he was and some
would actually argue it was the most
accurate depiction of superman's
strength that's been done in dc comics
for quite some time which if i'm being
honest i'm kind of inclined to agree
with others would say he was just wildly
overpowered for the sake of the story so
that's why tom taylor's writing when it
comes to characters you can't
necessarily take their strength levels
as he depicts them as an absolute truth
it's just one of many variations that's
why we kind of have a main dc universe
and just a baseline that exists out
there but the thing about this is that
it literally takes all these guys to try
to step in and do something and they're
literally trying to hold superman off as
best they can but we never actually find
out or at least we don't find out here
what happens all we know is they
seemingly haven't held in place and then
basically like green green canary is
like now right like cyborg inject him
and so what you end up doing is jumping
to earth 2 two days later and this is
cool because what it basically says is
like this is where the other heroes had
gone off to right they had basically
formed kind of a new world for
themselves a new earth and that's one of
the things to know that it happened
right at the end of the uh
main dc series that the heroes found a
new place to live when they arrive here
of course you've got president lane
right lois lane who's basically acting
president you've got guy gardner you've
got uh jon stewart the green lanterns
that we're usually familiar with but
while they're here suddenly they're met
by the arrival or at least the energy
signature of an apocalyptian force which
of course turns out to be a boom tube
but as soon as this opens their first
thought is like we're under attack right
like everybody respond but the thing
about this is that once the tube opens
is actually the good guys not only is it
the good guys it's this really beautiful
and amazing moment because you basically
get like superman who shows up who's
been essentially cured right not only
that when his arm was ripped off before
he's been replaced by a new arm which is
really really awesome so of course lois
lane is very excited to see her man but
then the other part of this and this is
probably one of the more beautiful
moments here is that jonathan kent was
also cured like the actual jonathan kent
right like superman's dad so now you
have like you have like the entire
family essentially reunited right
jonathan and martha are reunited the
superman and lois are reunited it's a
very beautiful moment here not only that
where you do have uh you have big barta
and you've got scot-free of course
they're cured again and their intention
is to go back to uh go back home to
basically new genesis or at least to
apocalypse or what have you and to find
their son wherever it is that he may be
because one of the things to remember is
that that entire area is in a complete
and total state of chaos and because
it's in a state of chaos they don't know
exactly where their son is all they can
do is just go to that realm and hope
that they can somehow find him now they
don't know that everything's bad but the
crazy thing here and what's really also
a bit of torment is you switch over to
damien talking to alfred and actually
revealing everything to alfred insofar
as they have a cure and all that kind of
stuff now the thing about this is alfred
would have found out eventually and so
it was really the the responsibility of
damien to say to alfred there is a cure
for the anti-life virus we can bring
everybody back the bigger reason why
alfred is so tortured by this is because
if you remember in the original deceased
event when batman when bruce wayne was
infected nobody knew what it was and
alfred had to kill bruce wayne and he
had to kill tim drake and dick grayson
he literally killed them all with a
shotgun so they're dead they're not
infected just kind of roaming around out
there they had to die and that's the
thing alfred takes it as a massive
personal loss and the truth from what
damian says is you would have found out
about this and so it's my responsibility
to tell you but there's no way you could
have known what would have happened
there's no way you could have known that
there would have been a cure developed
for this all we knew is that all these
different superheroes these beings out
there were infected by some kind of
zombified virus and they would have
killed everybody they could find or
infect everybody they could find you did
what you thought was the right thing at
that point in time but alfred still
rejects that and says like no i killed
my sons right and so it's one of those
things where as a father figure he just
can't let that go he just can't walk
away from this and so what you do is you
switch over to what is an effect about
the next day and you have all these
brainiac probes that end up arriving and
basically showing up to earth too now
initially they're taken out by like
superman and jessica cruz one of the
other green lanterns and so on and so
forth right the green lantern core
itself responds as you would expect and
so these probes are kind of annihilated
because their first thought is okay one
these probes are a credible threat
because each one of these guys are very
capable but two brainiac probes mean
brainiac's arrival is imminent and he
literally shows up hours later now
here's a crazy thing once they get to
the brainiac vessel they start to
realize that like something's wrong the
ship's in ragtag condition it looks like
it's basically limping along by all
standards of measurement this brainiac
ship looks like a car that's falling
apart and is out of gas and is literally
just kind of limping along the highway
until it just stops that's basically
what this looks like it's just in a
dilapidated condition and brainiac is
nothing if not meticulous and so this
idea of his ship just being torn asunder
and in little bits and pieces is
concerned for everybody because the
thought of of superman or at least the
thought of a jon stewart is superman can
you see inside right can you use your
x-ray vision to see and his response is
no that was one of the first things
brainiac did when he developed a ship
was to design it in such a way to where
i can't see inside anybody with x-ray
vision can't see inside to minimize any
weaknesses that this vessel may have so
the only alternative they have is to go
in right literally guy gardner's like we
have to go in there like we've got to
get inside this ship and we have to see
what's going on which means we may find
ourselves in a face-to-face
confrontation with brainiac now where
superman tells jonathan i'm going in you
have to wait here this is superman not
necessarily realizing how far his son
has come jonathan has been through a lot
and he's experienced a lot and grown up
much faster than superman possibly could
have imagined of course because
surrender was a zombified he was in the
sun no way he could have known but this
is not one of those instances when
jonathan stays behind and he even says
that i'm not staying here and so at the
end of the day it's jonathan and
superman who enter into the ship and
when they get in there what they find is
that brainiac is no longer a threat
instead like his body's been ripped in
half he's just kind of hanging there
just sort of strung up and he's like we
have to stop him the gods are dead but
they still come kal-el they will poison
the universe and the gods will end
everything with that being said guys
we're going to bring this video to an
end what a hell of a cliffhanger for
this first one we gotta wait a month now
and i will catch you all later
peace